on en vient maintenant à cette série d'
enquêtes que nous lançons cette semaine
elles concernent la vie sexuelle des
français en 2010 avec cette question en
quoi at elle évolué ces dernières années
premier volet ce soir les jeunes les
adolescents est l'un des principaux
enseignements vous allez le voir alors
que la sexualité n'a jamais été aussi
exhibé c'est que les choses n'ont pas
tant changé
les adolescents ne sont ni plus précoce
ni plus imprudents que leurs aînés
reportage nabila taboury philippe faire
rouler une pelle un patin ceux des côtés
bref emballé chez les ados les premiers
émois amoureux passent par le baiser
c'est vieux comme le mobile de roulage
de pelle idrac beaucoup mais on ne
conclut pas forcément car contrairement
aux idées reçues qui sont soit tu me
saute dessus comme ça en france l'âge du
premier rapport sexuel n'a pas beaucoup
varié depuis une trentaine d'années pour
les garçons les de 17 ans et deux mois
pour les filles il est de 17 ans et 6
mois dans les années 40 la première fois
pour un garçon c'était 18 ans époux ou
six étaient 22 ans qui fait les david
ont 18 ans un peu fleur bleue ils sont
surtout très amoureux ça fait un an et
demi qu'on est ensemble et puis bas
depuis un mois
c'est l'amour fou c'est john hurt et la
joie et les deux tourtereaux ne se
quittent jamais au lycée ils sont dans
la même classe de bac pro vente
leur histoire a commencé un jour de
rentrée scolaire par un coup de foudre
élevés des coupes là même son petit nid
le studio de david au fond du jardin de
la maison familiale entre eux beaucoup
de tendresse et d'attention une
complicité qui leur permet de parler de
sexualité sans génie table une première
fois vous l'avez vécu avant moi la non
moins oui chacun donne voilà à 16 ans
c'est jeune donc j'ai moins badghis
étron typhaine je suis senti à l'aise
comme sur des roulettes une relation
sereine et épanouie qui d'après eux les
fait grandir
mais la belle histoire peut aussi virer
au cauchemar
julie a 17 ans et demi lors de son
premier rapport sexuel c'était en mars
dernier avec un garçon plus âgé il n'est
pas représentatif
moi je prenais pas la pilule je mets pas
comment ça marche pour vous dire donc
que tu lui a valu qu'il fallait qu'il
mette un préservatif
bah si j'ai dit mais le imaginantes
c'est la première fois ce pauvre 1 julie
se retrouve enceinte elle décide
d'avorter sans en parler à ses parents
trop peur de leur réaction
depuis la jeune fille refuse toute
relation sexuelle j'ai perçu recommence
je veux pas que d'avoir une mauvaise
pour une nouvelle expérience que j'ai
j'ai une gallerie tout seul donc le
nombre d'interruptions de grossesses
chez les jeunes filles de moins de 18
ans ne cesse d'augmenter
8000 dans les années 90 quinze mille en
les contraceptifs sont chères et il est
souvent difficile pour les jeunes de se
les procurer un anonyme
quant aux informations les ados on
dispose mais ce ne sont pas toujours les
bonnes alors combien de temps peut durer
un rapport sexuel
les questions sont directs elles ont
toutes été écrites par les élèves
limites et qu on prend le temps qu'on
veut par contre on l'enlève camp depuis
plusieurs années maintenant cette
infirmière scolaire et ses collègues
organise des séances d'information au
moment où il va déjà cully voilà c'est
un des obstacles aussi à la halle à
l'accès à la contraception des jeunes
les jeunes ont fait ils ont des
difficultés à parler de leur sexualité à
leurs parents parce que les parents ce
sont les parents et que eux n'ont pas
envie d'aller dire à leurs parents
justement qu'il commence une vie
sexuelle et qu'ils vont avoir des
rapports sexuels
et c'est tout le paradoxe d'un côté rien
n'est dit de l'autre la sexualité
s'exhibe farc
avec internet et le développement des
vidéos depuis une dizaine d'années les
jeunes sont de plus en plus exposés à la
pornographie à 14 ans 61 % des garçons
déjà vu un film porno les filles sont
45% qui a déjà vu un support la housse
élèves de 3e benjamin loup mégane et
gabriel ont entre 14 et 15 ans
appelle-moi l'internet c'est leur monde
virtuel où à chaque clic ils risquent
une agression visuelle elle bien réelle
vraiment je me sens prêt c'est parce que
entre la télé avec ses numéros et puis à
la tête avec les images au risque de
déformer leur vision de l'acte sexuel
non mais bien sûr il ya des gros lourd
qui prêtent défi pour les pros des
chiens est doué cessé de louer gens
c'est de concert pour amener la guerre
de quelque 1,2 comme des objets à un
bout de viande quand il est trop pour
avoir assez de maturité vont comprendre
que c'est pas la vraie vie
dans la vraie vie typhaine et david
notre bébé couple y est déjà une
histoire sans nuages une relation
consommer pour hausser exprime avec
amour ils ont d'ailleurs déjà choisi le
prénom de leur futur enfant